لحظات مفعمه بالفرح عاشتها الفنانه
السعوديه الشابه جوري قطان عقب تتويجها
باحد جوائز حفل جوي اورد الاخير الفنانه
السعوديه ضفرت بجائزه الوجه السابع عن فئه
الموسيقى حيث تسلمتها من الفنان الكبير
راغب علامه الذي اعلن فوزه ولم تتمالك
جوري قطان دموع الفرحه والتي ذرفتها لا
اراديا عقب اعلان فوزها مؤكده فرحها
الشديد بالحصول على هذه الجائزه القيمه
بجائزه الوجه الجديد عن فئه الموسيقى
للعام 2022
جوري قطان
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
كيف كان شعورك بالفوز باعلان اسمك قدام
الجمهور كله في هذا الحفل الكبير
اه بصراحه اول اول يعني ما قالوا اسمي او
اول ما راغب علامه قال اسمي ما كنت متوقعه
ولكن كنت يعني حاطه يقين انه انا رح اطلع
على المسرح راح اتجوز بس ما كنت متوقعه
يعني يعني ما ادري بس مره مره فرحت
والحمد لله جوري انت كمان بحديثك خصيتي
والدك ووالدتك قديش كانوا دعم اساسي في
حياتك الموهبه بشكل عام تسقل وتدعم من
البيت اولا انا ذكرت بالاخص بابا وماما
لانهم من جدهم اللي وقفوا معي وهم اللي
دعموني عشان احقق حلمي اقول لهم من كل
قلبي شكرا انكم طلعتوا فنانه سعوديه اسمها
جوري
قطانيكي الفنيه القادم
لهجه مختلفه تماما لا طبعا
راح ااه اغني لهجات ثانيه واصلا انا بغني
لهجات ثانيه يعني همم بما اني شاركت في
برنامجين وفي البرنامج اللي شاركت فيهم
اللي هم نجم السعوديه وبرنامج بوليفارد
همم في البرنامجين هذه انا طلعت مواهبي
وكمان وريت الناس انه انا اقدر اغني بكل
اللهجات بكل الالوان يعني غنيت مصر اغنيه
الفنانين اكثر المطربين والملحنين تحب
تتعامل معهم جوري او تعاملت معهم في عمله
بصراحه الملحنين اللي تعاملت معهم همم
الملحن والى الان انا اتعامل معه وان شاء
الله راح ينزل عمل قريب ان شاء الله اللي
هو الملحن الكبير الاستاذ ناصر الصالح
فهو اكثر شخص او اوجه له رساله هو اكثر
شخص دعمني من الملحنين
وان شاء الله لنا اعمال قادمه وجميله وهي
اغنيه على حسب اغنيه الجديده اللي نزلت
على راس السنه هي من الحنه الاستاذ نصر
الصالح انه يراهن على الجوري بقوه شفتي
تصريحات صح صح
عشان مليون خاطر
حاضر
انت الوحيد اللي كلامك
اوامر
[موسيقى]
وخاطرك
عندي ترى
مو مثل غيرك وخاط
[موسيقى]
رك من